everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
going over the Philidor defense what
starts out with pani for pani five-night
f3 and then pawn to d6 now this is kind
of a solid but very passive move it is
an alternative to the move Knight to c6
which probably see a lot of kinds of
gets into the Rilo PES or the you know -
Knights defense for Knights game
if you familiar with those but instead
of that again it's just pawn to d6 I
don't typically play this a lot from
black because it is very very passive I
like to play more aggressive lines from
white and black I think it's it's more
fun but I didn't want to go over this
because I play white to e4 a lot in my
openings and I come across the Philidor
defense a lot so I kind of wanted to go
over the main lines the main idea is
that white has to attack this to kind of
give you guys an idea if you ever see
this defense how to attack it and then
if you do want to play out the field or
defense from blacks point of view then
just keep these things in mind as far as
how I'm telling white to attack this so
you don't fall for the same traps or
aggressive lines that white hasn't here
so from here we're going get into it
there's two main lines if you'll see
that white really has the main line is
pawn to d4 which has a few variations
that we'll go into and then kind of the
second main line which I actually prefer
I think it's much easier for white to
play and I'll kind of go over that in
the video as well it's just bringing the
bishop here to c4 again there's two main
lines the first one we'll go over is
pawn to d4 this is the main line I don't
play it myself that often I think
there's a easier and better way provides
a play but they definitely want to make
sure I go over just so you kind of see
it from here black has a few different
options he can always take with this
pawn granted he is giving up the center
of the board controlled with his pawns
here on e5 and d5 but from here y can
just recapture black if he wants to he
can develop his knight here to f6
attacking white can defend that bringing
his knight here to develop and then
black if you wants to again this is kind
of a passive building out that defense
hey bring his bishop here to e7 castle
on the Kings side and then try
or that counter-attack now again early
on he doesn't have to take the pawn he
can always if he wants to he can go into
what they call the hand hand variation
from here it's just 9 2 F 6 6 again
attacking this pawn on e4 the knight can
count now come to c3 defending this pawn
now the knight can come to the 7 you
know supporting this pawn here on e5
also supporting the the night here on f6
from here the bishop can come down to c4
putting a lot of pressure on this f7
square the bishop can now come to even
getting ready for black to castle on the
King side so if you know the knight came
down to to g5 black could Castle and he
would be okay but you know that's one
variation again still very very passive
from black instead of bringing you know
as Knight to f6 right away you could
also try you know Knight to d7 this is
kind of tough to deal with the bishop
can now come to c4 right away black has
a lot of different options but now he
brings his knight to f6 he's immediately
met with Knight to g5 really really
strong move from white as you can tell a
little difference before black could go
ahead and castle on the King side and
you know his rook would kind of be
defending this pawn but right now
there's no real you know clean way for
black to defend this pawn here on f7 now
if instead of the knight coming there to
f6 let's say the bishop comes here to e7
then blacks actually going to lose a
pawn and material y can go ahead and
capture here on e5 the smart move is for
black to recapture with his knight if he
does in turn let's say take with his
pawn then the Queen can just come down
here to d5 this is going to be a very
very strong move from white again you
know threatening mate right here really
really going to be tough to deal with
now if he does again capture with his
knight here after the knight captures
and the pawn captures it looks like
they've traded off but now then Queen
can come down here to h5 and this is
going to be again a very very strong
attack not only threatening a powerful
take here on f7 but again also
threatening this pawn here on e5 so
again a lot of different options if
black has another
that you could see for those players
that play the Philidor defense but then
want to try a little bit more aggressive
opening they could always try the
Philidor counter gambit which is pawn to
f5 you know from here I think you know
white can just bring the bishop down to
c4 there's a lot of different variations
in the Philidor counter gambit but you
know I've tried them a few times myself
I still think it's really easy for for
white to come out ahead there's no you
know crazy traps that white can fall
into but you know a lot of times you
will see if you start out with pawn to
d4 black may try to surprise you with
pawn to f5 now the second main line
which i think is much easier to play and
so that's why we're going to be talking
a lot about it today is just Bishop to
c4 right here again right away attacking
this you know vulnerable Square here on
f7 from black again it's vulnerable
because at the beginning of the game the
king is the only piece on the board that
protects that so if you you've seen a
bunch of the videos you know this but
again you know once the King castles or
he moves to the other side of the border
once a lot of people's pieces start to
get developed that may change but early
on again this is a very very weak Square
from here so black has a few different
options from here so I definitely want
to make sure that you're aware of this
since I am recommending it I think it's
again the easiest to play the first one
that you may see is just Knight here to
f6 now if you see Knight to f6 again the
constant theme is you're going to
immediately play Knight to g5 again
putting a lot of pressure on this pawn
on f7 you can't really take this pawn on
e4 because again you're now defending it
but you're also again putting a lot of
pressure on f7 going to be very very
good for white another move you may see
is Knight to c6 from here all you're
going to do is just bring your knight
here to c3 again kind of preparing if
you've seen the video for the legal trap
you're kind of setting up the legal trap
we're not going to go into the entire
move what we'll kind of go into the
basics of it but feel free to watch that
trap
I have it posted on the website and on
YouTube as well but definitely watch
that if you want all all the intricacies
but basically what it comes down to is
black doesn't have a lot of moves from
here as far as where he's going to
develop so a lot of times you know he'll
want to get his bishop involved into the
game so let's say he brings his bishop
here to g4
a lot of times people like to pin down
Knights two different Queens so from
here pawns just going to come to h3 a
lot of times again black will kind of
kick that back he doesn't want to trade
off right away because white can still
open up the board and then white will
have a bishop pair so a lot of times you
know players will just bring their
bishop back here to h5 but from here
white can actually play Knight takes on
e5 and this again is the legal trap so
he is kind of opening the door if Bishop
comes down to d1 and captures then it's
going to be mate the bishop is going to
come down here to f7 King can only move
here to e7 and then the Knights going to
come down here to d5 so again that is if
they fall for the trap the good thing
about the legal trap is if they don't
fall for it
you still have a really really good game
for white you still have a lot of
attacking lines it's not like if they
fail then all of a sudden you know
you're completely messed up your entire
game so again if you want more about the
legal trap there's an entire video on on
it that I made so you know we're going
to we're not going to rehash everything
in this video but definitely that's kind
of what you're going for if you play you
know just Knight here to c3 after Knight
to c6 but again if they don't even move
that then they you're just going to kind
of go along with your game you're going
to castle on the Kings side then you can
get you know your pawn here to d4 start
to counter-attack you know the center of
the board control that get your dark
square Bishop involved into the game
connect your rooks and you should have a
very very solid game next move you may
see from black is just you know Bishop
here to e7
and then from here the nice just going
to come here to c3 you know black can
now bring his knight if he wants here to
f6 and then why it's just going to
castle on the King side and this is
going to be a little safer from black
but a lot of times you won't see the
simple move
if you know Bishop to e7 because it's
you know you just don't see it as much
typically you're going to see you know
Knight to f6 you're going to see you
know Knight to c6 a lot of times you'll
hear nights before bishops as far as
development so if someone's not too
familiar with the Philidor defense they
can play Knight to f6 or Knight to c6
and get themselves in a lot of trouble
because again there are a lot of
different traps that they can fall into
so again white really doesn't have to
worry about a whole lot of you know
counter gambits and main variations that
blacks familiar with as far as like the
hand hand variation I think just Bishop
to c4 is very very easy to play it does
everything you want it develops your
pieces gets them in the you know
controlling the center of the board
it attacks weak squares so I've had a
lot of success with it hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video
learn something both from whites
perspective if you actually encounter
the Philidor defense and then if you
actually play this as black some of the
things to keep in mind as far as what
you should and shouldn't do now that you
know a lot of you know whites lines that
they have against it so hopefully guys
enjoy the video and I'll see you guys in
the next video thanks for watching